can't watch an RV music r b music video
without thinking like I think this guy
wants to [__] me
like there's a sheep blowing behind him
he's looking at the camera like oh
this guy you're all
looking good
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we got Tyler back
hey hey Tyler and uh we finally get to
meet Nick's children yeah I brought him
today I hope that's okay with you guys
Leon and Winnie Winnie Winnie the Poo
named after Danica McKellen she's named
after
um Winnie the Pooh I guess really that's
what Tiff that's a good Winnie also I
named him after Leon black from Curb
Your Enthusiasm
I was thinking Resident Evil I just
thought Leon was I was like man Leon's a
cool ass name that's cool man it is
Resident Evil yeah that's mine familiar
oh yeah that one too that one too I'm
neon Leon so today we are talking about
uh what is something that's popular that
pisses you off really gets in it grinds
your deals literally what we're just
talking about right now so right now
it's like uh can you play the one Biden
clip real quick okay so this is what
pisses me off right now and I've never
really been political because even like
when I was in the military like uh
people would be Republican people would
be Democrat they're all military and
they're talking in the workplace and no
one got their feelings hurt and they it
was almost like it almost actually felt
like they were talking about sports
we're like oh [__] the Bulls ah [__] the
Lakers and then at the end of the day
they're gonna stick to the guns but it's
like a friendly acceptance on both sides
now it's like they you hear the other
side as whatever and the wall goes up
and it's not accepting and almost like
I can't hang out with you I've uh during
like the heat of all of it in the
pandemic I've even heard people like my
mom's toxic I can't talk to her she's a
[__] like whatever and I'm like what
the [__] that's your mom dude like but
because she's a she's a trump supporter
Trump supporter or Biden supporter or
whatever no it's this clip of of Biden
this is this is Nick's president by the
way it's my brother maybe just between a
man and a woman and states must respect
that yeah
I get mad at is stuff like that if you
repost just to call out the
inconsistency the the social climate is
immediately you're a trump supporter I'm
supporter I [__] knew it and you're
like no I'm just going wait that person
changed their words quite a bit and you
know I mean we even see it in the
comments too like there's no such thing
as a moderate like we're not allowed to
be moderates which most of us are like
you have to pick a side and if you if
you pair it one side talking points then
all of a sudden you're completely that
you're a Die Hard alt-right or a super
woke liberal yeah it's fun on the show
too because like I think we're all kind
of trump comedy supporters like yeah we
all laugh our asses off at Trump [__]
all the time all the time and then but
then I'm also like yeah I think like the
every president we've had in the last
like 50 years is a war criminal yeah
yeah they're supposed to be yeah but
yeah no exactly what the BART said
what's kind of crazy though I I think I
was a trump comedy supporter and then
this year I think I became a trump
supporter no because like hey you could
only transition because all this so all
the [__] that he said like it was like
it was like like I believe in the
vaccines whatever and we need to build
the wall and all this other [__] right
you're like man that just sounds [__]
crazy you're laughing at him so hard and
then you see the the Border crisis that
we have and then in the board all the
people that are crossing over I think
they already cost three uh Afghans that
are on the FBI's Wanted list for 9 11.
oh my God like that is part of the
security where people think oh what is
it against Latinos that you hate and
it's like no [__] it's against
insecure or unsecured borders it could
be anybody it could be Somalian pirates
like all the bad people that are coming
in and I'm like damn I think his wall is
kind of like a good idea
the Somali pirates are just coming for
Treasure yeah oh that's true we don't
want anything x marks the spot give them
some Lucky Charms to leave that is a
weird thing that I don't like the trend
of Corporations being politically like
charged and also like
like standing for like more out like
moral causes and stuff like that because
like well they're just trying to sell
[__] but it's that's not even being said
but the people don't understand it's
marketing but they're kind of being
fooled like Nick buys rainbow leashes
yeah for his pugs right yeah because I
get it when a small business like on a
community level right like let's say I'm
showing them
today can I can I be honest though what
the [__] is that so look when I bought
them on Amazon this is my honest story
people don't believe me but you my own
sister doesn't believe me I was uh
buying and I couldn't figure out what
color I wanted to get so I was like oh
the rainbow one's cool so let's get all
of them so I yeah I got four of them and
then my sister saw me she goes getting
ready for Pride or what and I was like I
[__] hate your sister too I was like
no I didn't even realize so was your
sister like don't appropriate my culture
because you're not gay like me no she
just thought it was funny yeah
because that's the thing too like let's
say you like rainbow yeah now you're
immediately like gay pride supporter or
what like what what if I just like
rainbow like everything
also too Technicolor Dreamcoat
everything's so tight I'm just a
leprechaun all the games all the gay
dudes in my neighborhood with dogs
they're like extra nice to me because of
that rainbow leash that's kind of cool
so they're like you're an ally it's like
a hack I mean it's an ally but you can't
beat it but no see though yeah I get
beat up a lot yeah people
maybe that's
it after brown belt then for you oh [__]
yeah
when I was a kid I moved to California
from Virginia right and the teacher gave
us like this thing to color and I was
like oh cool like I'll just paint I'll
just color this Castle in a rainbow and
then after that the teacher was like
super sensitive around here and I didn't
even know the gay people like owned the
that flag get because it really wasn't
the case yet that's not fair dude well
they kind of she thought you were
getting those gay after that for sure
they stole it from the Hawaiians yeah
like the license plate in Hawaii is the
giant rainbow right and then it's been
like that for [__] decades I bet
they're like oh bro they just jacked us
bro
that's cool bro my mind's just so used
to this point like whatever I mean
honestly you guys can have the rainbow
back like I'm fine with that yeah can I
be a spokesperson like I don't we don't
want the rainbow anymore honestly I
don't want the rainbow either I don't
like the rainbow give it back to Hawaii
yeah give back to them they wanted and
Hawaii should give it back to the Bible
I like what you were saying yesterday
about how the rainbow like doesn't go
with anything no it's a fashion disaster
yeah it's so hard to match collars with
these guys it is though it's like
rainbow only matches with rainbow
because taika loves Rainbow because it's
all the colors yeah but then because
it's all the colors it goes with nothing
I just don't like how like like also
because like my hoodie right here has
some cool like rainbowy like type
patterns on the back that's more tie-dye
right that looks cool I want that to be
it because like when it's in lines like
this right yeah it's just very boring I
don't know are you dunking on my leashes
dude rainbows actually look straighter
to me because they're all exactly
they're all like exactly roygbiv because
they're not like but like when Tyler
turn around like those are actual
distinct colors that are different yeah
but then like this is so straight to me
and it's straight it's like red orange
yellow I feel like mixing it together
like that represents sexuality a bit
more like realistically as well because
it's more like more of like a spectrum
it's not like this line people aren't
like in these like myself
that's the news
symbol from now on I only do it's
straight right I feel like I've always
hated Trends and that's what got me into
comedy because like I never liked
mainstream when it was mainstream I
never liked things that were popular
when it was pot like it was good you
know the comedy got Trends too you're
either too early or too like like it's a
classic yeah like were you one of those
kids who's like you know in sync and
Backstreet Boys were like kind of fire
where you're kind of like I like it but
I pretend like I hate it I was that yeah
yeah I did that but the house I like
that I like the pop but it didn't really
ignite me the way that like certain
other music genres did like like Michael
Jackson that's probably the most pop
that I went but like other than that
like the Britney Spears NSYNC that genre
um I mean I listened to it but it didn't
hit for some reason I hate Backstreet
Boys and NSYNC but I know what alerts
don't know why
[Laughter]
do you like
I think when they first came out
and I was in high school I was like [__]
I want to kill these guys and then wait
what about Justin Bieber because every
like high schooler I knew hated Justin
Bieber like every guy hated it you know
what I think it is I liked him because
he was the generation was not like
competitive that's what I think it is so
like we were way older so it was like a
cute kid right yeah I fell for it I I I
really thought that he was some cocky
little kid and I was like [__] that
little cocky ass but then I watched this
documentary
no I did I actually really did he's kind
of a cocky kid in there he's a cocky kid
but he but he was so musically gifted I
had no idea I just heard his songs and
like baby baby baby I'm like this is a
[__] killer song dude wow and people
like wow he wrote this song I'm like who
gives you a baby baby baby
oh that's good writing to you like you
know I mean like I just was ignorant
about it I thought you were gonna be
sarcastic saying like you know how they
doctored a whole like thing how he was
discovered just off a random video and
then he wasn't already managed oh I
didn't know that yeah was he already
managed I think Scooter Braun had him so
they orchestrated that Discovery they
mildly did that's what I didn't like in
the documentary that fool was slapping
Scooter Braun every five minutes was I
slapping yeah he would just be like
surprised well Pat across his face
I don't know if I like this kid I think
I liked them before this documentary
that's why you got to read your contract
and just slap him in the face when I saw
him drawing I was like okay
okay [__] up I was like he's actually
pretty good amazing but I didn't know
that and the way that they presented him
and or portrayed him in the in media
that I saw which is like commercials and
[__] I wasn't like watching the same TV
that all the kids who loved him he plays
everything too guitar piano like he
plays everything I just didn't know I
did I did think it was kind of funny
though when guys would like look at boy
bands and be like oh that's so gay and
I'm thinking it's not for you bro like
of course like and it is gay
it's like it's it's for women like or
it's like it's like it's afford it's a
different audience right so like why you
why are you criticizing it as if it's
made for you I think that's when you're
younger your view is like that so that's
why I hate them because you're like you
think the whole world is made for me
yeah I hate this I hate this I hate this
and then you get older and you're like
oh there's there's a lot of people yeah
that's true can't watch an RV music r b
music video without thinking like I
think this guy wants to [__] me
I'll be able to [__] my girlfriend like
there's a sheep blowing behind him he's
looking at the camera like oh you're
doing I'm like oh this guy's trying to
[__] you're all looking at the screen
going
but that is how vain you are at that age
yeah at that age everything's about
that's very true but you do look at
things as competition when they're in
their same age rating yeah especially at
that level Justin Bieber was like the
same age as me so like all the high
school girls were like you know liking
him instead of the other high school
boys so the guys are like what what the
[__] like we're right here why are you
liking this random dude on the internet
that you're never gonna see yeah were
you actually a fan of Bieber though like
at all um I didn't like Bieber until
after high school like when you dropped
purpose and stuff I wasn't a hate I
wasn't a hater though I just thought he
was like like I knew it wasn't for me
personally of course yeah dang dude
imagine saying that the beaver's face
this wasn't for me but nice to meet you
it's not love me that's pretty good
can you hear me
this isn't my jam I don't like it
one thing that I think is funny is so
gen Z they think they came out with all
this slang but it's just Gay Culture
slang yeah it's all from Friends it came
from the drag clubs like the sleigh and
all that like that's that's not even
Millennial that's older than Millennial
slang like that's just like 75 79 yeah
that's like drag culture that's like all
that what if they start calling each
other Jive turkeys that's that's from
airplanes it's just funny like they
think they came up with that [__] and
that's their era and I'm all like nah
dude that's like old school yeah I think
it is old school now though I think
Soleil is kind of done am I wrong
I'm hearing Riz and all that [__]
printer print it the second we just said
it it's now done
if I know about it you just the end of
the era what about um any club clothing
styles of today that are popular that
you guys actually don't like
he's coming back like because I missed
it you know what's [__] nuts you know
what's on coming back
uh so when we were kids yeah like
specifically us three there's crisscross
right and they were wearing literally
their shirt the other way backwards
now the trend is moving in a direction
where you know when things come back
it's same but different yeah so people
are wearing it backwards but because the
designers know that they're just sewing
back pockets on the front of jeans now
so instead of wearing totally wearing it
backwards it's a forward-facing but
looks backwards and then they're gonna
wear that backwards so it just becomes a
regular shirt isn't that crazy I hate
that I feel like all the most popular
clothes I see right now that are
expensive looks like their finger
painted on like people like literally
just take like finger paints and like
draw like a sun or something and it's
like no it's high fashion yeah the low
effort look yeah yeah fashion is
interesting crunch graphic design
that is a thing it is interesting
because I feel like
back like when we were in like school
like people were inventing or like they
were making their clothes and they were
like it was it was actually a subculture
where like there was some form of risk
of being a certain style like right
right whatever right and then now
everything is commercialized to where
it's just fashion like tattoos just fast
is there a community there's no Edge is
there some culture that's getting
bullied now for looking different there
should be wondering I think the bullies
are getting bullied dude I think that's
what it is yeah I feel awful for the
bullies right now bring the bullion back
bodybuilders I don't know but like you
know how like athletes like maybe like
cyber Goths like maybe they're getting
married because they're so dorky they
have so many places to go though yeah so
many bridges that have underpass yeah
because it's it's like if you came to
school in Cosplay in the in the late 90s
early 2000s someone's [__] you up and
taking your sword away no yeah even even
like even in the early 2000s when I I
was like grunge like kind of rock [__]
people hella made fun of me but that's
also why like those kids would have
those chain wallets that they'll [__]
smack you with or like
you know dude I just look like a [__]
Kohl's ad
like my mom dressed me like a little
businessman
he looked old since he was a child I
looked like I had I looked like I had
like a beeper like you could have put
right here like a young Sheldon yeah it
was insane oh you know what I don't like
which is not I hate when uh when people
are not committed to like being a Gotham
what does that mean like if you if
you're just like gossed out to the max
like you just like white face like all
this like straps but then you get into
an Ultima and drive away
oh
Starbucks like a hearse you gotta have a
freaking purse yeah you gotta ride a
black horse yeah
I think that that is what it is like
before if you're in a subculture you're
committed to it nowadays everyone's
half-assing everything everyone's
half-assing yeah for sure I think
everyone's cosplaying like they're not
they're not in it they were always
cosplaying though
I feel like everyone's a little bit just
like mildly schizophrenic today so we
all have like 20 different personalities
within us that are like all trying to
like kind of surface because in the past
you just kind of went to your group and
that's like who you were around now
you're with your group and then you're
looking at like you know snapchats of
other people in other groups and stuff
so you're not you're not trying to
assimilate to this one thing we're kind
of trying to assimilate to so many
things that's true because there's so
much information and data out that it is
hard to stay on one thing and now
there's a there's a possibility for so
much more subculture so you can just
kind of dive in and dip your toes in all
the time right
that's true I guess it is easy to be
hyper critical when the information age
is way faster now you probably get tired
of your own Trend after like way shorter
of a time than we did you know the
algorithm shoves it down here I
committed a good four years to Nautica
and Hilfiger in High School junior high
Nautica
that stuff was tight though yeah that
was really tight I do think the end of
True culture is probably 2000 or 2010.
then everything past that is just
reinventions of the past dude you know
you know it's something I I listened to
recently that is a very good example of
that is this dude was saying he was
asking his son like hey what kind of
bands do you like what artist do you
like and he goes I don't know I just
like chill hip-hop on Spotify and he
goes which artist he goes I don't know I
just like listen to chill hip-hop yo
that is so he doesn't know they don't
know artists bro yeah that happened to
me because of lime no like you know like
um vintage band shirts and like those
things are really popular right dude
like a lot of kids be [__] buying
Brands and shirts that they they don't
even they're just like I like the design
they don't know anything about it yeah
I'll be like oh [__] you like [__]
train spotting they're like What's that
and I'm like it's on your shirt
it's like that's a movie oh I like this
picture
it's like okay oh dude you like the
Nazis not just like geometric shapes
it is kind of crazy they don't know and
I was like what the [__] well I wouldn't
be caught dead buying things of Brands
and like bands if I don't know it like
back in the day it's like when you wore
that [__] that's because you were like
hella into Metallica that's who you were
yeah you know like and then because
you're trying to like be like yeah I'm
into this and then they go oh you like
Metallica too and you make friends and
[__] right yeah but then like there's
hella people that just buy it because
they like their design I bought a Van
Halen shirt yesterday and I don't know a
song by Van Halen you should listen to
Van Halen you might like it yeah it was
a cool shirt though yeah I like the
shirt a lot yeah I don't know the albums
though people always go what are the
album I don't [__] know I don't know
no that's like that's too deep of a cut
sometimes for certain ads yeah yeah I'm
not like the [__] psychopath dude
Napster and torrent a just download
everything I don't know that that's
actually that's like it's like I have a
blink shirt I don't know every single
song you know what though ever since
Spotify and like Pandora and all that
um I don't know the names of songs so I
can see why it's chill hip-hop do you
feel sad because I feel like oh I don't
know I'm not connected to the artist
anymore I'm just connected to the genre
I'm not sure I could name a Van Halen
song right now yeah his example was
funny this comedian guy I could hear it
but I can't name the title and it's also
mixed in with 80s AC DC yeah yeah
for some reason I can't name like any
songs
except for that one yeah
thing he said it's equivalent to someone
asking you what books you like and you
just say helvetica and or if you said
what kind of food do you like soft
textures it's like it's because you
don't know what the thing is times no
you know the it's not [__] weird it's
weird it's weird I never thought that
would be a thing either have you seen
spotify's new AI DJs yeah I tried it out
yeah you were listening to your Tyler
suitable radio station now playing songs
that you were going to like and just
like talking they do play songs that I
like though which is crazy yeah they got
enough data by now we've been using it
you think there's a DJ out there named
DJ Ai and he's like uh my career's
ruined because when I'm working out I'll
type in like let's say like EDM hype mix
and then all the songs that come out and
then Geo's EDM hype mix it sounds like
Forever 21 like I'm gonna go shopping in
mine it's like like harder like [__]
like knife party or like bloody bleach
type stuff and I'm like damn this even
though we typed in the same thing it
[__] learned our choices it's like
within the genre who you like damn crazy
one of the other things I like is when
you go to an artist and that creates
like your own personalized radio station
with the artists and other things that
you kind of like you know kind of like
they know how to make adjacent playlists
my brain so good yeah you find a lot of
cool stuff that way people like the kids
listen to this are like are you guys
[__] serious that's so old I know
they're like we dig in record crates now
morons
laughs
foreign